MODOK is possibly the strangest
character ever created by the folks at
Marvel an evil giant head with arms and
legs MODOK is bent on taking over the
world and he's also incredibly goofy so
will we ever see him battling the
Avengers in a Marvel movie well let's
find out originally created by Stan Lee
and Jack Kirby MODOK first appeared in
1967 tales of suspense number 94 as a
faux fur Captain America at his core
he's exactly what his name says he is a
mobile organism designed only for
killing as far as origin george Tarleton
had signed up to work for the acronym
loving science terrorists of advanced
idea mechanics only to find out that he
was the dumbest guy in the room
admittedly there's a significant chance
of that happening when the room is
otherwise full of mad scientist but
George had the opportunity to get a
little smarter by letting aim experiment
on him the original intent was to turn
him into MODOK with a/c instead of a
cave the mobile organism designed only
for computing whose genetically
augmented brain could help aim with data
processing unfortunately he became way
more aggressive than they anticipated
which earned him a more accurate acronym
and took the position of scientist
supreme in the process George was
physically transformed with his head
growing so massive that his body could
no longer support it requiring a
floating rocket chair to move the
trade-off though came in the form of
mental superpowers
MODOK will have power beyond anything
man has ever seen his very mind is a
weapon over the next few decades MODOK
would be a perennial foe in the Marvel
Universe with aim becoming a sort of
utility player supervillain organization
that could reasonably go up against
almost any hero a group that's entirely
devoted to Mad Science for the sake of
Mad Science directed by the
incomprehensible whims of a giant
floating head can show up pretty much
anywhere through it all MODOK was at the
center of Ames advanced ideological
machinations
now a few of his most memorable exploits
during this period involved creating a
giant robot body that was properly
proportionate to his own giant head so
that he could fight the whole a plan
with so many problems that she really
start to understand why computing wasn't
really his forte he also once teamed up
with the headsman a group of d-list
villains united by the fact that they
all had weird heads in an attempt to
take over the world that's the kind of
story that MODOK was winding up in and
it would only get weirder from there the
life of a MODOK is a lonely one when
what is designed only for killing can
they ever truly know love if motox past
is anything to go by the answer is a
resounding no but that's never stopped
him from trying to create some kind of
mutually attracted technological entity
to ease those lonely nights of plotting
world domination the first attempt at a
mate came when shield scientist Kate
Waynesboro was transformed into the
imaginatively named Miss MODOK she
didn't last long
turning against her creators and
eventually stumbling into some kind of
reverse mode occupying machine that
undid her transformation
the second was slightly more successful
by a set of very specific standards for
success a woman who's originally thought
to be Hank Pym dead first wife Maria
underwent a similar procedure to George
Tarleton the difference was that it only
caused her brain to balloon to the size
of a small Zeppelin and not the rest of
her head since she wasn't mobile she was
initially designated a specialized
organism designed for aggressive
maneuvers or so damned eventually though
she finished the complete MODOK
application and having been granted her
own rocket chair she became modem
perhaps surprisingly modem and MODOK
never really hit it off as you might be
able to tell already MODOK found his way
into some of the Marvel Universe's
weirder stories in fact he would
eventually come to be a symbol of the
weirder side of Marvel himself maybe it
was the purple and orange design that
made MODOK look like a malevolent easter
egg maybe it was the innate hilarity of
the phrase designed only for killing
maybe it was Eddie sometimes seemed like
the one villain who was allowed to be
incredibly silly while still being
presented as a deadly mastermind
whatever the reason he went far beyond
your average weirdo villain and became a
true cult favorite inspiring fanzines
like the pseudo scholarly journal of
MODOK studies and occasionally
angling his way into a starring role
with all that in mind what are the
chances that he'll show up in a Marvel
movie someday well they're probably
better than you think
MODOK has never really been the go-to
villain outside of the comics but that
hasn't stopped him from making a handful
of appearances in slightly more
mainstream media he's appeared on a lot
of the Marvel animated shows albeit with
some notable changes starting back in
the 90s with the Iron Man cartoon that
made up half of the Marvel action hour
aside from changing the K and his name
to stand for conquest the big difference
there was in size rather than just being
a gigantic head perched precariously on
top of a comparatively tiny body he was
shrunk down with the end result being
that it was about as big as your
standard-issue toddler with the head the
size of a basketball why they changed it
remains a mystery but given that the
shows of the era were heavily tied into
toy lines it might have been that a
slightly smaller sized MODOK was easier
to make as an action figure that could
fit on the same size card as the rest of
the line regardless of the reasons it
gave us a very memorable scene of a
genocide 'el supervillain going
undercover and being pushed around in a
baby carriage it did beyond that motox
most surprising appearance probably came
in the world of video games when he was
added to the roster of Marvel vs. Capcom
3 spades of two worlds as a playable
character you might think that being a
giant easily targeted head with
comparable tiny arms and legs would put
him at a distinct disadvantage in a game
about punching people in the face but it
seems like he's a mental organism
designed only for Kos out of all motox
various media appearances the strangest
might be the one where we find out he
already technically exists in the MCU
okay when we say that MODOK is
technically already part of the MCU the
word technically is doing a significant
amount of heavy lifting he has indeed
made an appearance in an official
installment to the MCU but it's not one
that most moviegoers would know about
he's an Iron Man 3 the official game to
be fair the video games are dubious at
best when it comes to tying into the
actual MCU after all the games aren't so
much contradicted by the movies as they
are completely ignored by them but they
do give a few underrated characters a
chance to get a little closer to the MCU
than they would have otherwise the
Captain America tie-in games for
since have some really great deep cuts
like diamond back in the militant
anarchist forces of ultimatum
as for MODOK the version that shows up
in the game has an interesting twist to
him instead of George Tarleton this
version of MODOK is Aldrich Killian the
mastermind behind extremists who dies at
the end of the movie apparently he had a
contingency plan which involved backing
up his brain and then becoming a MODOK
to get his revenge however the biggest
factor working against Murdock's chances
for showing up in a film is that he's
actually getting his own TV show it's an
animated sitcom starring Patton Oswalt
in the title role and it will focus on
motox home life with his wife and kids
as he faces a midlife crisis now really
that's happening it'll be on Hulu later
in 2020 the set up of the show is that
after failing to conquer the world
despite many many attempts MODOK has
lost control of aim facing a forced
early retirement he now finds himself
without a purpose in life because you
know he's literally designed to do one
thing in addition to Oswalt the show's
cast should be pretty familiar to fans
of TV comedy Amy Garcia whose previous
comic book themed credits include
playing crime scene investigator Ella
Lopez and Lucifer will be playing motox
wife Jodi who runs a mommy blog they're
two kids high school senior Melissa and
tween Lou will be voiced by Melissa
Fumero of Brooklyn nine-nine and Ben
Schwartz who may be best known for his
role on Parks and Recreation originally
MODOK was set to be part of its own
bizarre shared universe of animated
shows alongside fellow Marvel Universe
oddballs hit monkey Howard the Duck and
Tygra and Dazzler as the offenders the
deal wound up falling through but MODOK
will continue on regardless all right
let's say that Marvel Studios does in
fact want to work MODOK into their
universe but they don't want to use him
as a villain maybe they're worried that
having a bad guy with a giant head
fighting a superhero is the one singular
fatal flaw that turned audiences off of
the Green Lantern movie so how do they
bring him in as always the comics have
provided an answer as the success of
Suicide Squad proved audiences can get
behind a heist story about a bunch of
misfit
supervillains if they're looking to do
their own villain centric action comedy
romp then the MCU movies could do a lot
worse than lifting the plot of
supervillain team-up motox 11 as you
might expect from the title motox 11
involves MODOK putting together a team
of c-list villains for a job that
involves steel
massive potentially catastrophic power
source called the hypernova none of the
other characters involved have been in
the films but the basic idea of
reuniting the MCU surviving villains
under Murdock's commanding cranium could
make for a super fun movie it could be
the perfect vehicle to bring back minor
characters like back truck or the
baddies who've been on ice due to a lack
of sequels like the abomination let's
say Marvel Studios wants to go a
different way and fully embrace all the
weirdness that comes along with a
rocket-propelled giant head that wants
to take over the world with his brain
powers there's a comic they could draw
on for that too and it might just be the
single greatest MODOK appearance of all
time it happened in the pages of the
kid-friendly Marvel Adventures The
Avengers number 9 the premise of the
story is simple when the Avengers raid
Ames headquarters MODOK uses his brain
powers to lure them into a chamber that
turns them all into motox the problem is
that there's still the Avengers so they
break out in their own rocket-powered
hover chairs and continued doing Avenger
things the funniest part is that while
they carry on being superheroes the
public is completely weirded out by it
and everyone reacts with less cheering
and more wit just quietly being
disturbed eventually Wolverines mutant
power counteracts the MODOK
transformation and he's able to reverse
it for the rest of the team before they
decide to take over the world to run it
more efficiently let's be honest this
doesn't seem likely to make it into a
live-action MCU project but consider the
following given how eager they were to
finally move on from their rigorous
time-consuming Marvel roles having Chris
Evans and Robert Downey jr. come back to
voice computer-animated MODOK versions
of themselves might be the only possible
way to get those guys back for another
MCU appearance check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite comic
characters are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]